Film Courage: When I go to your website for
THEN THERE WAS JOE, I notice you have a ton
of press from your home town or surrounding
areas and they seem so welcoming.
How is that to know that yes when you come
to your new home in LA it’s a different
ballgame, it’s not personal but there are
just so many people doing the same thing.
To be so embraced and cheered on and then
coming back here knowing that you have to
be your own cheerleader.
Justin Warren, Writer/Director: So what’s
interesting about (and this is kind of my
strategy actually for making my first film)
I wanted to do it in a place where I’d be
supported and because the crazy part is that
anywhere outside of LA outside of California,
if you make a movie that’s newsworthy because
it’s just not a normal thing that a lot
of people do but out here in LA everybody
is making a movie.
And I hate to use the term everybody but a
whole lot of people are making stuff to the
point where it’s relatively normalized.
Like for instance whenever I go to a coffee
shop, if you just look at people’s laptops,
9-out-of-10 screens some one is writing a
screenplay.
And that is not normal anywhere else outside
of LA.
It was amazing, we premiered my film THEN
THERE WAS JOE with the Arkansas Cinema Society
which is run by Jeff Nichols who directed
MUDD and MIDNIGHT SPECIAL.
I was great because they saw my film and believed
in it and were going to put it on a premiere
for it.
There was just a level of excitement that
I just haven’t experienced anywhere else
because it was a bit of a hometown hero kind
of vibe but also people just truly went to
the movie to enjoy themselves.
I think sometimes here in LA we can go to
the movies to judge, that’s why we go.
We walk in and are like “This better impress
me.”
Back home in Arkansas it’s almost like a
magic you walk into this dark room with other
strangers and it’s like “Okay, what’s
going to happen.”
And being in that posture of about to watch
a film is a totally different vibe.
And I think that actually most of the world
experiences movies that way.
Of I want to go and I want to be entertained,
I want to be moved and I want to have fun.
And sometimes living out here in LA it can
be easy to lose track of that because we try
to impress our filmmaker friends “Did you
see that dope shot on that thing?
It was tight right?”
I knew that the thing I was trying to make
is for an audience to consume.
It’s for people who live lives outside of
the entertainment industry.
It’s about regular people going through
what they’re doing and there’s reception
at the end.
And I know sometimes when I’m shooting my
scripts to friends or they shoot my their
scripts I think it was like George Lucas or
something who said “There are only like
seven plots.”
And there is some truth to that I think.
But just like you can only make car one way
really.
It usually have four wheels.
It sometimes doesn’t have to have four wheels,
you can make it with three wheels.
But the reality is that I think the majority
of people will usually give a movie a chance
in ways that sometimes after you’ve gone
through film school you’ve already decided
“I’ve already seen this before because
I know where this is going.”
And you’re way ahead of the movie.
And you can get into that habit and stop enjoying
films.
And so what making my feature taught me is
that it helped me remember what movies are
for, what they do and what they mean to me
and seeing that in Arkansas was just a beautiful,
beautiful experience and rejuvenated me and
made me want to keep going because I got really
scared after I finished my film because I
was so tired, I was so exhausted.
I had a moment where I was like “I don’t
think I’m going to do this anymore.
I think I might be one and done.”
And something happened when the lights went
down and everybody got quiet and my movie
is a comedy drama, it’s a dramedy if you
will.
But the first couple title cards it’s a
joke and it takes you a second to get it because
it starts and then there’s another title
card and then another and then another.
And everybody immediately busted out laughing
and I’m like “Ahhh, they’re in.
They get it.
They get it.”
And I showed that to a lot of my friends out
here and they were like “This is dumb.
This is really dumb.”
But I knew it was funny.
That’s another thing it’s taught me (this
whole process) it’s like trusting your voice
and knowing that your voice and your opinion
about something is totally valid.
And even if it’s standing outside of a group
of people and a group of people don’t agree,
if you feel strongly about something, there’s
probably at least a million other people in
the world that feel the same way.
And this process (the notes process) we were
talking about earlier helped me to know when
to trust my voice.
Film Courage: I think you said your family
has this unofficial rule?
I saw this in one of the interviews that you
did “If there is something you’re afraid
of that will make you a stronger, better person,
that’s probably the thing you need to do.”
That’s great.
Justin: Yes because I think fear is probably
a really good indicator.
It’s an indicator of your destiny in a really
weird way.
I don’t want to get too new-agey in here.
Film Courage: Hang on, let me turn off the
incense.
Justin: But to me in my brain I feel like
there’s a better side of you on the other
side of fear.
Because things I’m not afraid of are things
that don’t really mean that much to me.
I’m usually afraid of the things that mean
the most to me.
Right before we launched the Kickstarter campaign
for my film, I had never experienced that
much fear in my whole life because I was like
“Oh my Gosh, this is public.
If I fail it’s going to be public.
Everyone is going to know about it.”
And so there was like a week where I didn’t
post it and so I was like “I don’t know
if I can do this right now.”
And so thankfully I have a really supportive
family and a really supportive wife and they
were like “You have to do this.
You have to.
It’s your destiny.”
And I’ve noticed that every single time
where I’ve been utterly terrified and I
pushed through it, I’ve only succeeded.
And I don’t mean that in like an arrogant
way, I mean that in the sense of like I jumped
off the cliff and suddenly a trampoline appeared
right before I smacked the ground.
And that has happened so many times like for
anyone who has put together a feature film,
you understand that.
You know that those things happen.
You kind of move before any of the pieces
are in place and suddenly magically the pieces
are in place.
And I now love that feeling, sort of jumping
off to see “Okay, is something going to
catch me.”
And nine times out of ten it does and when
it doesn’t I’ll figure it out.
And that’s been a recurring theme throughout
my whole life.
If you’re afraid of it you have to do it.